all right and we are live welcome to the
i lords podcast episode number 71 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable and the Lord's
Day I'm extremely excited about our
special guests so we go get right into
it I want to introduce a lord who in my
opinion has some of the most passionate
and balanced gaming perspectives and all
these youtube streets this Lord is a
true multi-platform gamer is an
extremely charitable member of our
gaming community and has authored some
of the most thought-provoking articles
you ever read on TI c games network.com
introducing the host of the gaming
perspective podcast and writer /
panelist of tix
ol multiverse show the chief of
achievements game is true king of the
north and by far the best Canadian
accent you ever hear on YouTube making
his debut into the realm of the Lords my
man Lord undead 3xv I I'm doing pretty
pretty good I didn't figure out who
you're talking about
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
in the making
so it's good to have you Lord in Rome
respect what you doing out here
appreciate being here Dow and of course
you know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those usual suspects active
roundtable Marcos with the code most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the how of
the young wolf mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good I do want to say that I will
be announcing the you know the streaming
schedule and stuff for the streamers
deaf would be looking out for that no
doubt absolutely pleasure to have you in
the realm today and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Damas mister off my profile Illuminati
and Lord patron of the iron bank
mom-in-law sovereign how're you doing
sir what's up guys doing well man I hate
yesterday's first week and I got two
actually I got to sit down yesterday
watch baseball I can't be mad at you
guys listen I don't associated they put
a better product on the field there a
big market team shopping it one more
with you and it far enough removed from
the Madoff stuff that not be an excuse
anymore
Boyka I've have an entire boycott with
the Mets in baseball until they resolve
their issues actually turn on one of my
consoles yesterday so though of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this
a.k.a the excess gamer oh the lord of
combat sports was a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the game
buddy gave I'm doing fantastic your ex
but look at your watch this is about to
go down
I know when it's about to go down I
wanna highlight I'm gonna highlight a
lord and a friend to the realm hip-hop
gamer yeah he did today
he was on the Lisa ever show on high 97
this morning talking about the gap in
gaming and hip-hop that is brought
together and how the culture is pushing
our genre forward you know San Diego
comic-con is going on right now and we
are a part of that because they show a
lot of video games there we get a lot of
our material for videogames from comic
books and other mediums so I just want
to give a shout out to that their Lord
that he's out here repping he's working
hard at 6 a.m. and I'm driving and I'm
listening to him on the radio and I had
to shoot him a text and say man thank
you so much and congratulations for all
your success because this guy never
stops is the humblest guy whatever
opinion you may have of him I'm glad you
said that King yeah I know listen that's
my dude and I know we don't always see
eye to eye on certain topics as far as
game is concerned but Azzam as a man
like that is a real dude like if a real
dude yeah yeah I would definitely if you
get the chance definitely talk to that
brother he's really really positive down
I don't agree of like there's no denying
it that like when it comes to
straight-up
passion towards the industry there's not
really too many people that surprised it
yeah he keeps the same energy with you
it's just a beautiful dude and I just I
was just so happy as I was driving to
hear him and listen to the topic so I
usually when Lisa Evans come on in the
morning I turn it off I'll be honest
with you today
they got my listenership because my
fellow Lord was in the building and he
was repping and he was doing it
well you know so he was up there with
some heavy hitters you know he was
talking about Queens of map and how
influential Queens rap is to hip-hop and
they talked about the stigma of hip-hop
and Queens and how they know means
resolve because you know hip-hop just
moved from Brooklyn to Queens so that's
where that beats right so then we had
the whole boogie down in Queens before
that oh so good to see that's good to
see no doubt yes shut up today's very
positive and of course we have the
gaming engine himself the shinobi Laura
Cognito
spread never illness in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lords are playing
this week I want to start off with Lord
undead his video game system history his
journey as a content creator and of
course what led him to tics Oh
multiverse show and tonight hosting the
gaming perspective so Lord undead I
start with it from the beginning man
what would like some of the first video
games systems you had like what got you
into gaming well well the consoles
weren't allowed in my house growing up
because my brother my older brothers
were PC guys okay so we started on I
started with PC and I started with games
like heretic Hexen doom I was like four
years old but strange of those my mom's
logic behind it was though it doesn't
look that realistic so it's fine
yeah I remember I would never forget one
day that uh uh it was way back before my
mom really knew what games were about
and I committed was it was one of the it
was an Elder Scrolls game and it was
rated in and I went to gaze stop doing
that dude behind like he he he said just
like you know this is rated M he's like
well you know it can't be that bad
don't you mess this up at that time I
was really young yeah that dude just
like he looked at me he gave me that
like you know what man you going through
we'd be good I remember I was I was 6
years old I went with my brother my
brothers like 10 11 at the time we went
in there they were buying a GTA like
grand theft auto the original Grand
Theft Auto V so we go to the PC store
give the guy money four days looking at
he's like I don't think you're old
enough to buy this game my brother just
looks up straightening iron goes all
were taking it anyway it's ran out of
the store it's like you've ran out and
they just grab you is like we didn't get
the mall but we got one instead of going
home he ran to our friends house and
it's already a school yeah so like I did
that growing up I played like I go my
friends has to play like ps2 and 64 I
start getting those experiences and
first console I actually owned I just I
think I cut lawns for like four months
across the whole street to buy a
Gamecube my first one that I actually
owned was an n64 cuz you know I'm not
like an ancient compared to some the
other how many months four months you
must have been screwed what
on every week four or five ones
everybody every week and it took you
four months egg of it you know what it
is you probably bought the Gamecube with
probably like ten games that's problem I
also keep in mind Canadian economy's not
that great for the first one give me
some give me some stand out undead
GameCube game save you don't say Lois
first games I bought and played on the
Gamecube was Luigi's Mansion Resident
Evil 4 obviously like Mario Kart Double
Dash because if you got siblings you
need that level of physical abuse in
your life Smash Brothers all those cat
games and I also I bought the Gamecube I
bought that adapter for the gameboy
games underneath I didn't have to buy a
gameboy yes like Pokemon all that kind
of stuff and it was great and then uh
after the Gamecube I bought the Nintendo
Wii and I went this sits in there I'm
like I'm like 13 or 14 years old I'm
staying here waving emotion code and
controller my basement this is not the
it was down with that man stomping you
know we don't anything I'm with you
here's the thing like we can't win was
the ball yeah we can't forget the
cultural phenomenon of the week right do
we change the game we're like your mom
what we sports had me in a liberal
sweatin with Ali boxing experiences on a
console yes and I was in the late
getting it like really get until I found
out that all you had to do is really go
like this
before I found out that you really had
to sit down and just go like this with
your hand and you didn't have to really
get into the mix I love the weed but it
in its lifecycle the worst game I've
ever played was created so into this day
because it butchered the up into that
point I never played any any Legend of
Zelda game I didn't like until Skyward
Sword came out I want you I want you to
stop that because we had this
conversation already and I would like
you to step away from there
this is we go move on from that which
games well I actually the main reason I
bought the we right off the bat is I
think it was Guitar Hero 3 launched that
day and I was like I looked at my buddy
I was like we need this oh yeah yeah I
was like he's like but I don't got a job
I'm like well I'm firming houses right
now so I'll buy it so I went out bought
the whole band endless nights of not
sleeping playing guitar hero till like
4:00 o'clock in the morning and then
when I decide I wanted like branch into
a more traditional console on the fence
between ps3 and xbox360 and I actually
decide go with the fat ps3 right on what
mate what made you go that direction I
would ps3 because like how many lawns
did you move for that let me say
something okay
you didn't hear everything that he just
said right and I'm this is where I'm
gonna have to call fraud or eat because
getting them dum-dum Duckett's because
he said that it came out with guitar
hero he wouldn't bought the whole set
you know that's that set costs a pretty
penny right now when he brought the
PlayStation 3 he said the fat one notice
he said that that was yeah the fat one
that was $700 okay it was $6.99 and then
I don't know about the inflation or the
cost of money up there because I
understand that the difference the ps3
iPod or plus taxes and everything it was
a thousand and thirty so you're not
fooling me when you talk about cutting
grass you had a team cut the grass
Butchie and you getting that apparently
like you know like homies brother don't
mind you know like playing the
Fivefinger discounts I didn't want to do
you bet pretty big thing was the
correlation was is I really enjoyed
video games but my family wasn't didn't
really have a lot of money while I was
growing up so we didn't have a lot of
the video games that's why we went PC is
because the back then with pcs didn't
really have to upgrade at all yeah most
part so that's why my brother stuck with
PC gaming but SUSE I got a job at 14 I
was framing houses I was bringing home
like a brand new wing I was like okay
now we're talking humble do me and I so
like in like a 12 month period I bought
the Wii with the Guitar Hero bond all I
bought three I bought the Xbox 360 I
went through like four of those because
damn red ring of death yeah I started
playing on both of those
my fat ps3 died two years after after I
bought it so I kind of like yellow the
yellow bar got the yellow bar on it yeah
yellow nobody talked about the yellow
light of death
it was real yeah so like I was like okay
well I don't really wanna buy another
ps3 because it was a little pricey I was
already had a 360 so I just decided I
traded in my like arcade 360 and bought
the black xbox 360 elite mmm-hmm I just
uh I kept getting 60 started doing halo
tournament start doing tournaments nice
doing the fours and everything with my
brothers and friends and it was it was
great great time and then actually I
think you're the first guest it really
say like I won one of the first that are
basically said that during the start of
that let you know last generation that
they went there with ps3 initially any
other standout status you know like the
Last of Us or anything like that or the
thing with the ps3 why I went to him was
because I basically bought the ps3 on
the grand or the ps2 right because it
was like oh well the ps2 was an absolute
barn burner and amazing console so I was
like it made it made sense and like none
of my friends had Xbox I gotcha makes
sense and everyone bought ps3's and was
like well this is the point because I'm
trying to think myself in that time if
I'm ps2 was fantastic
and you probably kept the momentum but
it brings me a parallel to like a lot of
the 360 guys that kind of kept the
momentum and stay loyal the Xbox brand
and going to the Xbox one kind of deal
kind of you had almost a similar
mentality with the ps2 going into ps3
yeah and I ended up doing the same thing
with the 360 going into the Xbox one I
was actually one of those people when
they were like oh it's always online and
everything I'm like groovy I got good
internet I'm with this whatever
yes yeah no oh boy in DJ said the ps3 to
like a George Foreman grill he did look
like a George Foreman's world with the
spider-man logo with spider-man neurons
clean kids
opened it out the box though how it felt
like you thought that you got just 699
world laughs you pulled it out all the
money was very shiny it's in out the fat
one didn't that one caught me from Royal
Kingdom
was that the one that had the backward
compatibility right yes and let's also
remember at launch because there was a
big lawsuit after this personally
removed it saw help me out didn't they
have Linux as an OS in the ps3 oh no you
can add it they had it so you can add
yes right and when they removed it then
people sued because you know the
pretense that you know all your systems
would have this and then I guess as they
came up with later iterations they
remove them as well as the backward
comparison
this is why you could tell the mentality
of the PlayStation Wyndham Ember they
got burnt before so that backward
compatibility stuff they work the
hardware out with it instead of software
they put it inside the box and they
notice that the attach rate of these
guys playing older games wasn't there so
they removed it so you can understand
why all these new systems they don't
care about going backwards they got
ripped already a new one I was doing
that so they don't care this history man
loving these systems these games took me
down ps3 lame and it's def what are the
first guests that really you know rocked
out very auto and that's what starting
obviously transition to the ps3 so I
know we've been talking a lot about
Canada and gaming in the north so
explain to us Lord in there like give me
the whole vibe from obviously the most
remote here not in from Canada like as
far as gaming and I believe we asked
Kofi this question as well like what's
it like just gaining in Canada like what
was give us a lot it's like in the
States except with worse internet hope
he's actually complaining about the
internet yeah yeah I'm good that way but
bad because a American internet is
pretty is not the greatest so if you
guys are worse than ours
we are both need to work together it's a
different vibe in Canada like I'd like I
don't know because like I didn't join
social media to like the later stages
like I didn't join social media for like
gaming stuff until like after the Xbox
one ps4 launch but like it was always
like where I lived it was always like it
was cool to be a gamer like that was
fine when you went to school and you
played video games I was fine
yours fine is the guys that played
sports I did both so it's having nothing
oh we playing would you play basketball
6 7
I played tight end high school football
for four years I did MMA for six years
yesterday I did a lot of things like I
did like I started doing like I did I
started karate when I was 4 years old
that's what my mom put me into because
she didn't want to put me in hockey or I
think to stereotypically Canadian
questions like how did you avoid the
hockey influence because my family's
Irish immigrants so like they don't feel
the whole hockey vibe they they're more
the shout out to your parents i'ma give
a shout out to your parents yes I feel
that I wish you don't see my house
during a Conor McGregor fight you don't
even watch
yes yes yes I do trust me yes I do
I'll be right there in the middle which
I'll put your kid in hockey up here like
right now and it's like the fighting I
grew up with I've got six brothers two
stepbrothers and a sister and I'm one of
the smaller ones are you sit what of my
oldest brother David he won the Canadian
experience getting some some inner
knowledge behind the scenes let's get it
to like the YouTube journey so obviously
where I first came across was Lord Amen
on the multiverse so how did that start
can't you get to no nor take me okay so
anchorman I met through on Facebook
because we used to be part of a Facebook
group called we game here
I heard about that to edit and we used
to go back and forth all the time and
basically me and him became friends
because we were both Bethesda fanboys
[Applause]
so basically fallout 4 trailer came out
and her messaged me on Facebook I was
like wheat we - this whole group for
them all you're his partner got your is
it enabler yeah we basically trolled
that group in let me give you yeah you
you guys are the reason I left
constantly posted like pictures of I
remember when fallout 4 is about to come
out anchorman had like a different
looking train everyday train well guess
what anchorman so I started talking to
anchor that way and I we ended up
leaving that group or whatever and I
went to a different Facebook group or
wherever and he's like you should start
a Twitter it's fun that's exactly what
he would say it's funny she continued so
so me and him talk back and forth I
started with a group called hard knock
gamers they started a website up and I
started writing for them initially and
that was me Fame demigod reviews a
couple other guys that were we're we're
writing on that site and doing stuff
that way for a while like we gave user
gone for about it was up for about six
to eight months yeah yep so we had that
site gone it was popping pretty good and
then Hard Rock gamers got absorbed by
the inner circle which is an all too
familiar scene for a lot of people shut
up to take baby let's go
the book yes sorry I started as writer
there and anchors like yeah yeah and I
actually started but I started doing
podcasts because hard not gamers had a
podcast which was called the writer's
block podcast which used to be me Fame
kid Smoove wasn't that was one of the
ones could smooth hosted would not yep
yep that's why that was one of the ones
that was me kid Smoove Fame there was a
guy named Matt okay and Nicodemus as
well kid's name is kid smooth don't
believe in like restarting a podcast if
he stops doing a podcast for like two
months he's just gonna do another whole
new ball so we start on that anchor was
like hey being famed do this show we do
the multiverse show it's just two of us
you want a guest on it I was like sure
whatever I'll I'll show up so I did like
an Epson and they're like hey you want
to come back for the next episode and
then I've just never left waiting for it
to message me the one day be like yeah
we don't need you here on Monday you can
your contracts been don't man so did
obviously you know we have Nana what we
know you for is the gaming perspective
so uh I believe we got our lords Eric
Jackson rage virus and of course Lord
editor Santo BER who is on a lot of
podcast by the way Sam went from not
being on any podcast to all in one week
because it went me and anchors talk he
was like oh you should have Sam guest on
your podcast I'm like sure sure so we
had to say about podcast this is great I
want just before my podcast I messaged
Sam on Sunday I'm like hey you wanna you
wanna become part of the podcast arrive
right I'm way
response in the anchor messages Villegas
oh we just got Sam locked in for multi
podcast I'm like oh well let's see how
this goes in Sam's like yeah I'll take
on a third one I'm like you the man I do
podcasts and I suicidal multiple times a
week so I cannot even fathom even begin
to understand what that Lois Sam is a
beast like that only is he to like if
I'm convinced he doesn't sleep I'm like
people don't like I'm convinced that
he's actually a robot batteries his hair
sleeps because like I'll put an article
pending at 3:00 a.m. l DM and be like
hey this article sing for you when you
get up I'll get message five minutes
like oh it's posted so Danny was a
pleasure working with a mentee three and
uh hopefully more future things we have
playable no Sandman great great do great
great team you've got what undead cuz
you got Rory our exec Sulli he enjoys
perspectives went well it was the friend
of the ROM as well and braaap and then
of course lot of Rage valve just getting
to know and um really really cool do so
that so what kind of like you just said
it actually got the Sam part so they
let's bring in how to arm our Jackson it
and rave fires coming up well see the
original the initial idea is a gaming
perspective because I bounced around
starting my own podcast with anchorman
for a long time and I would originally
what I wanted to do was I want to do a
revolving panel a guest spacing and then
I started to realize how much of a pain
in the ass you get guests every week
yeah especially multiples and they're
not have cancellations and everything
else so I decided to do is I get a core
group of guys that I want to get
on a podcast invite them for a one-off
and then see how the vibe was yes so I
got I got Eric rage came recommended
from anchor because we hi diverse than
he was like he's Canadian so we got me
rage headed off me and Eric have always
always talked rate I've been on rap once
or twice and it was always great
so a gang era was fantastic and then
yeah it was just it just the stars
aligned right to get the exact people I
wanted for that podcast which is
fantastic because I didn't think it
would be that easy like I was figuring
it took me about ten episodes tiring out
who I'd have on my panel and it
literally solved itself in two weeks
no delve a that's a great group and I'm
looking forward to the journey man you
guys getting started when I seen the
lineup uh say yeah that's gonna be so if
they stick with it that's gonna be
something cuz you got a little bit
everything different perspectives and I
love the name like tell me about the
name gaming perspective well originally
what the gaming perspective was gonna be
it was back where I actually thought I
was gonna have time to do a YouTube
channel I was gonna do like a Friday
topic breakdown every week and that was
gonna be why I was gonna call the series
and then I sat there and that's actually
not a bad branding for a podcast like it
and then I was like no one else does
podcasts on YouTube so this is like a
totally original idea the lanes there's
no competition in this I love it a lot
like I said gets people to think in like
I said one thing about you on Twitter
that I like you one of my favorite
follows because um I think your bone in
reference to say things that need to be
said that a lot of people and I don't I
don't necessarily consider you like a
person that follows the trends and stuff
like that you'll say what I feel is
important and definitely like I said
you're not following Lord on dead please
do man really really cool Twitter follow
and uh just good dude
so out this a person question I learned
it tell me the whole meaning behind the
name like what is ready that the undead
we XVI and this goes back to the 360
days
okay so originally my Xbox gamer tag
which I think cow won't kick me off the
podcast if I say this it was originally
pony or nuts pwn you and that's why I
use for a while I was playing Halo
competitively mmm and couple of me and
my friends were like we should make a
clan mm-hmm okay
I was like so what should we which we
call it you're like oh no and like I can
remember what the theory was I think it
was like the 3xv I was supposed to be
six and then your slow sees the three to
multiply the six my one friend came up
with it was the most convoluted clan tag
of everything my wife threw down our 20
bucks and like nine of us changed her
like there was there's myself there's my
friend who's beyblade 3x VI variations a
lot of those guys don't game anymore and
whatnot but we we were pretty solid back
in the competitive days won a couple
thousand dollars doing Cod tournaments
and everything I traveled stateside did
some MLG events and so what I'm hearing
is you're the one that carries anchorman
through a pretty much eat the best but I
come in stalking that smoke this is
basically I'm the guy they anchor when
he talks trash he's like hey hey you get
this game yeah when I called when I
called a boss and I was going at your
boss I noticed that all y'all was
stepping up and you're trying to shield
the boss I got this
I'm not kidding like when we when we
play Rainbow six siege there's a game we
were playing where with six siege it was
me and multiverse guys and we're playing
or whatever and we wrapped up the game
it was a complete sweep I was like I was
like nine and one anchor was like oh and
one but he had more like spots he spent
the whole time on cameras they had more
this man had more points than the IED
nine kills and this may have more
employment points than me on spots and
he looks he literally says to me in the
parties like well you might want to step
up your game then I'm always the the
backup guy and that that's the same
thing as like when we want to do Rainbow
six siege against you guys he was like
oh that was a fraud nobody was listening
to the show he a challenge that he came
at me with I said it I wasn't even on
the show yet so and then I challenged
him one on one and the whole team was
trying to man like that private pvp is
in destiny now I've got pretty good base
on what FPS I can play I ain't gonna try
to square off against you boys really
really cool but I get I give a anchor
credit for the Rainbow six siege
challenge because he was like oh we're
gonna get the guys to practice and then
he's like I also got my friend Morgan is
improve plays ranked a lot Oh Mike
I told you all things will be revealed
couple of shows we got a leaky faucet in
here today has been drinking
oh hey could cause you're cheap
achievers and one thing about you on
deck
you're a beast out here in these games
streets cuz you know for a fact I just
have a little bit easy undead story
there's a there was one month where I
wasn't playing destiny though I think
it's before destiny to launch and I sat
to myself and I said you know what I got
to do this I got a 1 month for my game i
sear and all every time I see undead
every tell all these guys on my friends
list that I just killing it with game
with score for the book and even adding
so I'm sitting I'm like you know what
i'ma go hard one time extra extra hard
right every telltale game was finished
that my obsession to Megatron - he was
partly because I remember the people I
was battling and friend it was making
sure it was all and then it was undead I
remember like two days I took like a
little break I came back and you were
like within you know 450 hundred bucks
to go I had to go extra extra hut you
out whatever because your people don't
know I did goes hard
please muzzle your team with me how did
yeah I think I said my record for the
most I ever sat down and did and one
month was like thank 21,000 that's the
only time I could justify staying down
and doing that because that requires way
too much coffee
some of those achievements required me
to be on line that leads me has every
guess this Lord Undead
your top 5 games or franchises of all
time for that
[Music]
boy like stealth huge use though you a
sovereign will be friends yes yes this
one ourselves number three to put you
out there but you're like going to turn
25 I get it
I'm just a halo 4 number 2 just because
your time that I spend on that game
number one yeah it's gonna be God War
wow so now let me ask you what you were
got a war like from the jump
even we'll see what this yeah Yatta war
like like my brother be God like the
original God of War I think we beat at
least 10 to 15 times Wow tremendous
tremendous is hold on we have a
violation in the chat rage virus said
tenchu is in the bushes we have to now
remove him from door to do chat attack
that I'm sorry that is the ultimate
ninja game where all the ninja games
were doing that creepy magic you know
that's crazy stuff that game broughton
into stove into it
that was stealth before metal gear
softly yeah yes and then our last one I
had that element with the Xbox one at
the four player co-op on that one but we
don't just play with your advice but
don't you dare send it again Oh any
history Lord that love love what I'm
hearing the game's lit the history was
lit don't get into what the laws have
been playing so what have you been
recently playing what's what's going on
Xbox or Playstation
I'll see I'm I Bob PC there a month or
two ago okay so kind of been dabbling in
some old games okay I've been bouncing
between dark forces which was an old you
taking it back
and baldur's gate - oh wow suggestions
for friends just know these were games I
played with my brothers all the time
that I was like that's a nostalgic thing
actually history that's what you start
that's right yeah it's just good to get
back into some of the older stuff and uh
I've been playing pub G you played all
the Jedi Knight games or just dark
forces I put all the Jedi Knight games
like this because he's young but he's
got the porridge so pretty much has been
memory lane peaks in memory lane pub G
just just chilling lord adequate even
playing sweet pretty much handle Wars -
and fable that's ice
I've been playing a lot of Halo Wars -
because they just did the final patch
and won't pretty much made it to where
uh if you want to win a game just go
- Hornets no doubt getting ready for
that new fable announcement next year
you get already fit as if you feeling in
your bones
well I do feel like I'm gonna play them
all again but uh I got to see exactly
like I'm not saying the fable the new
favours gonna be bad I'm just saying I'm
a little skeptical of people who race
cars making a game called fate and
there's nothing like bad against them
it's like know that you know one Lord
Richard was on you know he said that
people there that you know they may open
adventure games like everyone that makes
a game like a racer doesn't mean
everyone only has why people have all
when you see people make a racing and my
Forza horizon they're like yeah we're
making an open world action-adventure
game you just like scratch your head
like what maybe they might bring
something different to the genre that
hasn't been done it you know open their
minds up so listen you know what I'm
gonna give him a chance because he met
you know you want my opinion I think
that my croissant cos they said
playground wasn't up for sale like they
said they like their independence but
when they wanted to make a fable game I
feel like Microsoft used that to
persuade them to let them purchase them
she looks a little lost Sam you said
playing that program is building a
second studio for fable you need not be
concerned Lord Sam all the audios keep
screwing up my beloved franchise you
know fables like the last thing that's
left a lot of things I understand you
what the period you see my purity with
the Final Fantasy was Final Fantasy 3
when the job system and everything was
in there so then I go all the way back
to that fun point
but but to be honest with you I really
enjoyed this one that's the one that
yanked me away from my xbox and for a
very long time God walking evil and
yanked me away from my xbox uh like that
that inked me away you remember we just
going back and forth talking I'm like I
got to go because I got to play on this
PlayStation I'll be alone in the void I
was in a voice seriously be honest with
you when they came out with the app and
I was able to talk to you guys by being
in the chat and playing that's the same
time that that stuff came out and that
was the best thing for me so I consider
the FOMO was gone so I can play my mom
my final fantasy while talking the hot
monkeys on his own xbox and that took
away that that problem so I like the
game I get where addicts coming from if
it's my beloved franchise I definitely
you know your yoga antennas oh yeah
who's doing what and yada yada yada Lord
solve what you've been playing this week
now you got chance to turn on consoles
yeah well I mean I actually I'm playing
a lot of the hollow knight on the switch
like then down the metroidvania is Malik
you start opening up things and then you
remember where certain things you
couldn't get to before you have this and
then that opens up the whole can of
worms like man you just get lost and I
mean an image great control super tight
atmosphere the game is beautiful yeah
and then on home consoles yeah I turned
on my playstation oh because I had a and
it's to play some and they'll be the
show no and then I remember like a month
ago a month ago I had gone hard on
getting back into horizon zero dogs i
yes that one Zelda came out I sort of
left it here in the rear view mirror and
then that came I had my issues with that
game in terms of like the gameplay
getting repetitive you know just certain
things about the world being super empty
but again it's a post-apocalyptic world
but it's a beautiful game but the one
thing two things that that game does
really well is like character
interactions that conversation between
characters that it really brings out
personalities and the story you know the
chat is going in on you right now they
but this is the thing though right
everybody said that I've never said that
there's fire that game got boring
I will say this story all of you who
stopped playing mmm for four reasons
that I completely agree with that story
is bonkers oh okay so it's a slow burn
like a story is Skynet but on some other
level like story is worth it to be line
the story and forget about everything
else you know I can't wait for fable
addict I'm waiting for moonlighters that
come out on the switch you guys will
actually play it I do want to get I'm
not playing it on my xbox a game like a
little bit of a shout out like that that
20xx game like if you got a really good
game for the battery staple that's the
dude right there we got chance to beat
him at our packs and King was making
friend platforming in that for you
taking the sub just basically the gist
is give it a chance
it's alright to forget about the rest of
the stuff the rest of stuff does get
boring and repetitive the story it's lit
beeline the story okay morning now you
got my attention back I definitely got
to get back to that all that stuff man
no doubt more King aha it's so crazy
right now shout out to the clan alright
if you're not in IOPS I am Lord podcast
clan on deck is something wrong with you
I'm going to tell you right now I want
you to go there I want you to go to your
xbox I want you to add me I want you to
add a dick I want you to add sovereign
whenever he's on Lord Cognito um time
story to popular belief I am NOT the
only admin you know like you know
yelling at me talk about
I got welcome all the people hit me
alright how much dough I want y'all to
get in alright let me tell you something
we have some serious trihard so imma
give a shout-out to a young Chris I'm
gonna give a shout-out to T for these
hands already got the black spindle with
the catalyst almost complete dan Savage
our team is running so hard in a Chapman
I don't have the gun I was trying
yesterday and I did eight hours trying
to get that gun eight hours okay I want
you to understand how my day got folded
the majority of that is sitting there
waiting for that day instance to start
on yeah it is crazy and when it does
start and you kill a dude you feel so
vindicated when you get into the world
it is the wildest jumping puzzle if you
can't jump don't do it you're not
getting the gun he's right but I did
hear shout out the Lord come on sue I
did hear from the authority that there's
a way to get past all the demons so you
know you don't you know you have to do
those jumps mm-hmm also I was playing
pub pub she had a big date and uh death
and I got in the world and I just got
killed it was something crazy to happen
yesterday shout out to death and hot
monkeys that's always down for that and
l-boogie who's always down for that
smoke that's the other kind of punchy oh
and listen shout out to the stream team
you guys already hitting the floor
running I keep blowing up my phone
every time I'm sleep put y'all on mute I
got that chat on mute because you guys
go in smelled oh you're the man 100% I
got you a shout-out but please
destiny is back that feeling there last
week about putting stuff into the game
the Queen's mysteries that that's all
this and this is not a big thing and
this is stuff that was in destiny one
this is what you're not you guys hooked
in the begin with you give me something
I don't I don't have any idea why it's
there
well just follow the breadcrumbs into
something and then you have people
posting videos about how do you do this
how do you do that like man that's what
creates it - oh you're right softer
Damas you are correct you see you
literally said if they were forward and
then act this week what um yeah if
that's what you got okay I'll jump in
real quick um yes okay same thing does
need to pretty much all day you know we
just talked about this on flashpoint
with all the boxes it's almost to that
point where I'm getting back to becoming
a full time nesting play again and it's
just what soft says just what King said
you know that that mystery it's like
they finally understood why people love
their game and why did you know that
departure what they did at the launch
was such a bad move so ah yes you
already shot about all you know I'm
saying on Christy for I mean I'm is a
beast I want to shout out a couple Lords
Lord our monkey Lord addict obviously
risky obviously you Lord King we had
that little start with the Leviathan
reign and give chance to flowing but um
y'all finish that you know shout the
Lord t4 I mean that man is a tactician
he runs a tight ship as a destiny player
and he's really cool to play with -
shout-out to him it's in the right
direction right now I'm just working on
my Polaris polaris Lance I just got it
we're gonna Levin on the catalyst
working on leveling the the graviton
Lance Cratylus I believe and then um
outside of I mean outside of the black
sprinter that's just one of the coolest
things yet that's happening but I'm also
got a chance I just got the invite for
the Master Chief collection program will
make it even better so I'm definitely
excited about that one touched at this
week shout the Lord dizzy I'm on check
out on this vigor game that he keeps
raging about so once more already top G
should be ashamed with themselves
because this game that the head David
Pope G explained to fix all of it they
have to scrap everything in that engine
though the engine and the bushes start
off from a whole new engine at this
point King David
the way I think one of the key reasons
that for tonight is pulling such far
ahead of them is because they can do
that like quick reaction but like we
were about the season every two months
because they don't have to go through
that you know plus they made this system
I'm really thinking that you know that's
what they need to be able to do that
quick reaction they need to just take
that out and do it yeah I just redo it
that that's what I said - I completely
agree and shout out the Lord Requin yo
for being an evil influence he uh he's
like you don't even get the October but
I'm like I can't justify it right I got
too much I haven't played get into the
strategy right now he's like no lot of
people that you don't think game in a
manner that they do yeah that guy is on
this switch and I listen to the chat now
watch you guys all the time he is a
pusher for co2 Co he's a he's that
diggity octopus I get you go ahead and
like I said I just trying to stay away
from I heard too many good things and I
got too much in the back look to even
touch it so here he come
yo this time I go he's 60 whatever I
can't he's AI yo free demo so I'll go
search and I yo ain't no free demos I
can't do it he's like yo he's an
attending account you get it directly
for the website with a direct link to
you switch my life tell you like I'm not
saying the game looks phenomenal
especially you know my background in
that in that genre but like I just be
looking I'd be slight yo is that $60
like really well I didn't like I get it
it looks phenomenal but it's like at the
same time it looks like something I plan
a 3d like they should be forty bucks man
it's it's like I'm playing like Zelda
you mean to tell me those games are the
same price like what but I am gonna test
them on low recoil you have enabled some
some BS but I'm going to outdo it
because I can't get out of free
we three he said yo get your stats
transfer over if you do buy it I'm like
all right
wasting why know that if there's been
too many people that I respect in this
community that have like flaunted the
stuff like I'm gonna only negative thing
I've heard about the game is that when
it comes to the past like if you think
it all circles back to some big grand
like thing it doesn't they're all eight
individual stories you don't thoroughly
coincide with each other so there's no
big grand thing yeah you're not saving
the world anything like that the main
complaints I heard too from a couple
people was that some of the boss fights
really really drag a like talking like
20 30 40 minutes
oh great though then again yeah these
people could have been either under
level they might not know to really play
the games I think that they will be
trashing the game they know you know I'm
not saying anyone that made these these
so let's get the pole down in NZ topics
alright so last week polls are in and
the people have spoken with Microsoft
Nintendo execs in games like for at
night pushing the idea of cross
progression how important is cross
progression to you as a gamer to have
this feature the winner at 63% in a
fairly convincing three-way ILP poll is
the cross progression is the future of
gaming group coming in at second place
at only 22% was cross progression is an
overblown feature group a covenant at a
very close third place that with 15
percent of the vote is y'all just mad
Xbox a switch about losing NPD group
thanks to Leslie I propose admit what
does Lord undead think about this
progression I did a whole article on
cross progression on how it was gonna be
good for the industry as a whole and
everything else I think it's good I
think it's I think it's the new way
I think it's the future especially when
so many people are now buying multiple
consoles like there's so many even
casuals that now own Xbox and
PlayStation it like for me for us
progression why I eventually get my
switch later next month it's it's it's
huge because like I play warframe on
Xbox for example like I love warframe
fantastic you know if I was able to
carry my progress over to my switch and
be able to play warframe with my friends
on my xbox and then turn off the game
grab my switch hop on the train and be
able just pick my game up from there
that would be that's what makes for
tonight on switch so appealing you know
exactly I think with such a focus on
mobile gaming and streaming like
Microsoft says they want to put
everything on everything and they want
and the switch is such a mobile like on
the node ice and everything I think
cross progressions almost a no-brainer
at this point and I still stand by the
fact that PlayStation will bring back
another handheld mmm I think if they do
that cross progressions an absolute
necessity and I know they had cross
saves for a lot of the games for the
video which was good very good
and I think cross progression is just a
huge thing I think if I think cross play
is gonna take a lot longer for the
industry to adapt to but I think cross
progression is a good first step and
making progress in that area anyways no
doubt shout - DJ sing a check he said
you're my favorite now Lord undid
warfarin for life to these topics like
Lord Kings say we move a little slow so
you got picked up a little bit so I was
gonna set this thing off talk about
Gamescom um and obviously we know this
is arriving the Lord's will not be
probably most likely making it this year
we got another obligation we're gonna
hit but there's still a lot of things
going on and I kind of want to start
with the arm obviously let's before we
start which side to start with as far as
what's going on so pretty much you know
obviously Microsoft right they're gonna
be out there at Gamescom you know there
was a big controversy about a hardware
Mike self announcing Hardware out there
they got these 20 streets and in a tizzy
I'll shout out to Tom Warren and the
verge go any first is a Major Nelson his
personal blog post initially I guess he
had a black post I said a hard way there
then I guess they did like a major did a
spell to edit weird I guess they
realized like they don't wanna confuse
people as far as there being physical
hardware but actually like wow I don't
even really feel like it's fair to say a
stealth edit like he he messed up on the
wording of his article in he corrected
it like right my case like that happens
a lot doesn't it I mean III don't have
too much of a big of an issue with the
problem only I will give Tom Warren is
that Microsoft has a history of this day
dis is not pressing they've done this a
couple times where they've had a post or
something like that and then you go back
to the post and certain things change or
never
and that's fine that's fine as long but
his point is just own the mistake and
just say that correction or whatever
which I don't know problem but I Tom are
warrantied go extra hard so I do see
your point he went extra then you have
like people like games spa like making
the same article 5 times just naming it
a different so pretty much that was that
and um you know if that that was one big
thing in the obviously with my on Xbox
they pretty much say they're gonna have
like 25 games different genres you know
they'll expect it Forza horizon for to
be there Ori willing to risk stated the
case to daybreak crack daybreak pack
will be there and then obviously for
king pub key with the new mode will all
be day being there on a which got at
Gamescom
so that's pretty much on the Xbox
presence and then obviously the Sony
stuff so I want to start with the Sony
stuff actually so what do we think Sony
could or would bring to Gamescom nothing
that you look historically Sony doesn't
really care about Gamescom historically
they don't usually unveil anything I
think we're gonna see a couple of things
like I think we might see that medieval
remake that they announced but they
didn't bring back up at e3
I think Sony's go
to really see you to trailers like will
see a Bears game show and that's all I'm
with I'm with addict on this is they're
not gonna have a drum solo and then
it'll shoot out the flute I think
they're just gonna show the same stuff
that showed at e3 I think games come for
them for the most part Gamescom is
pretty redundant on I say for the most
part cuz there is some surprises that do
come from it but traditionally speaking
we're gonna see the Resident Evil 2
remake we might see some you're gonna
see some more spider-man footage
obviously I think they'll show something
else which I don't know why they need to
increase my height level for that game I
don't know I don't even understand at
this point I see some ghosts of Tsushima
stuff your possible to stuff it didn't
just go show pretty much what they
showed maybe some different stuff but
it's it's rehash from e3 I think okay no
now fair enough fair enough
lord attic you don't think much from the
Sonics are you not confident they're not
gonna so like nothing like I'm not even
being sarcastic like they are legitly
not gonna show anything what did they
show last year do we know remember kappa
anybody remembers off time what they
showed last year wasn't it was ami game
is they sure like a thumbnail trailers
on the her I think it was like either
their first or was so pretty much do you
think they're gonna save it for like PSX
and I gotta drop something on their
YouTube channel at the same time they're
big on Paris games week so that's that's
their thing yeah people need to realize
that like they really don't care like
you
today they are going to in what let's be
real here like what are they what could
they even announce life so even though
three Christian and half whole daughter
stuff I wouldn't put it past them that
they don't do anything
III just ended and like they didn't
really show anything new so like you
know maybe I think they might try and
then they just dropped a spider-man
story trailer so I mean like it dropped
at at Gamescom which is in like two
weeks I doubt they have anything Lord
saw what do you think about Sony at
Gamescom what do you feel they might
show are you not - it's gonna be if they
show anything is just gonna be rehashes
of III stuff maybe a little more footage
like undead said like maybe a little
more spider-man stuff because that is
there's nothing after I believe Paris
games week is after the launch of
spider-man so this would be the place to
give the final push for spider-man mom
although I just it's kind of redundant
people really excited for that game I
feel like they're they're showing too
much of spider-man - like yeah I'm on
that path a little bit - attic and I did
like I kind of feel like a like but I'm
not I feel you going so that's pretty
much I think that's where they they show
out and that's same thing for PSX they
just holding the cards for that started
saying Tobin and cherry said uh sony has
paris games week and tokyo game show to
worry about they won't even be present
at Gamescom bar uh both so not much for
president king do you agree with this
yeah I don't ever see them making that a
priority I see Microsoft making that a
priority more than them don't know I
don't sees Donnie you know making it a
priority at all you have an agreement
with all the lords you know I don't
expect a huge presence um Lucas table
via of VR flute controller for those
decision I could see them dropping a VR
game on you yeah I would say like I
think we may see some VR stuff possibly
you know I mean I don't expect nothing
huge maybe wanted to live life if they
did a conference against conscious
nothing but VR stuff you I can show ya
oddity trolling is your food man
you know that oh the body them like I
said I still think they may have like a
couple of announcements you know I'm
saying just to kind of get their name in
the air but I I do agree with the Lord
that um you know I don't really think
that expect a strong strong presence so
it's getting a Microsoft aspect of it
obviously we know what was gonna be
shown and obviously the Edit whole
situation but I'm gonna set this all you
know for me Gamescom still is important
to them you know import important to me
and and for them because at the same
time they just came off the goodwill of
III and I think I need to keep the
momentum going and I don't know if you
remember last year and then we actually
hatches subject and I kind of went in
because it remember Microsoft the
gamescom last year oh boy I wasn't a fan
I wasn't a fan he announced me oh I
didn't even mind like the bowl full of
controllers because like because that
was coming to different regions so they
were like you know and plus like people
people get mad and I'm part of it I have
you know stating that you know like look
I can get mad that they you know show
the same stuff they show - III but
people keep forgetting these are
different regions like like people need
like not everyone from Germany is going
to watch eath right facts and that's a
good point
especially like the reason that the
controllers was such a present at
Gamescom last year is because that's
open to that point the control the
design thing was in Germany and they now
say it was coming to Germany and that's
why the controllers was there to show
the combinations and stuff you know boy
so cute after you get perspective after
the fact ft done raged off is the fact
that your tone has changed - right that
I said the same exact thing I'm talking
about no opinion but you could sit there
and have a perspective of something
that's not you you okay hold up for
having a more broaden horizons from a
different perspective
oh no I see an S this is where you and I
it's the same thing I have I'm a very
I'm I like I imagine why I say from the
perspective of me very similar to me
when you first see something and it
aggravates you you'll fly off the handle
about it for the first 24 hours and then
when you take a step back and you look
at it it's a different it's a different
vibe for it you one of those people that
commit the murder then be remorseful at
I was saying they're watching the
Ubisoft show I had to sit there watch
that damn dancing panda everything I'm
saying there guys it's fine it's worth
it because Splinter Cell will be here
[Laughter]
that's the Ubisoft press conference I've
never sworn so much of my life I was
angry I went on Twitter I like sweets
and then I sat there with it's not that
big of a deal that got mad again I like
I go we're like addicts coming from on
that like it made sense why they did no
but but it it's easy to get mean it's
Twitter they do this same exact trailer
and the same exact thumbnail crap this
year in many different region I'm not I
don't buy that you know that did they're
different reasons stuff I don't buy that
at all means III if you're a gamer I
don't care where you are and you're
trying you're gonna find a way to what's
it like here's the thing when you're
when you're doing that you can't assume
that everyone in that region watch like
three let's say you just wasted time of
my life that I won't get the highlight I
come with you because at the end of the
day solving with you at the end of the
day yes you're right for the person I'm
just gonna go back to the ad world
I don't want I agree with yes I mean
addicts mean a great point yeah you
wanna you gotta understand some people
or not are in the regions that haven't
seen it all I'm saying is that for the
most part you know it's a huge event and
just to even add something additional
right no reason why they had the same
track I was really talking about you
know the controllers and stuff because
that that feature wasn't in that region
to event showing the exact same coach
yeah that's when they lost me yeah the
same exact trailers if they added
something afterwards okay week this is
the this I don't even we have more I
don't want to see the anything saying
like if you go to any kind of region
like first off why are you showing like
the that region the same thing you show
the Americans like it makes no sense
like technically we like you know we
have different cultures we probably like
different stuff why you show them the
same okay exactly which which you so
that's pretty much and the last thing
obviously we know home you know with the
whole you know thing I want I want to
get our perspective out here it like the
whole Tom Warren versus Larry her stuff
edit you know editorial etiquette kind
of thing sorry I didn't get your opinion
on that like did you what did you feel
about that whole situation you think Tom
Warren went in too hard
I just think not necessarily the one
into hard but it's something that needs
to be addressed and we've spoken about
this about you know fantastical
headlines just against and things like
that we've definitely seen it on the
YouTube side where you will see a title
for something and you'll click in there
and then it has nothing to do with
specifically stated in the title of this
video and you know I just talked about
this one game perspective yesterday
right this point you know Microsoft
should not be doing this especially
Microsoft if they've been there the ones
have been accused of flip-flopping and
and you know and and funny language you
know when it comes to like what is it a
launch exclusive or whatever the record
right be is clear and concise as
possible if you know oh well you're not
launching actual gaming hardware exactly
they are launching gaming hardware when
it's like a custom hardware system if
it's a Gears of War system or you know
because we don't have that new Xbox one
x system except for the launch exclusive
system we don't have that new system
PlayStation has a hardware launch with
the spider-man so you have to understand
it's a different SKUs you know when you
when you write that a certain way you
know and that's the thing it could have
been but of course if we're talking
about it get them talking about hard way
then launch it home Phil just talked
about hardware are they coming out
earlier if that was kratos went in oh
great one when that happened cradles
went bonkers he started going at him and
that was like a legit like on purpose
like I don't even understand what they
thought they were gonna get from that
like what those courses what know like
what person that acts
keeps up with this stuff let's be real
here is anyone in this panel think
they're gonna announce this scarlet at
Gamescom I mean anybody anybody any
hardcore game with common sense knows
that that was not a scarlet but not
Delaney and that's where I got a kick
and I do think there is a journalistic
responsibility that has to be kept and
the only thing I do agree with Warren is
that you know this is not the first time
though right much has done this before
and you just like you know and then you
said senior man like wait a minute hold
on it was right here now I don't see no
you know what
so I think yeah he went hard but at the
same time you know is a level of
journalistic integrity and this is your
base you have to be very concise you got
to be very clear because people will run
with it not to your point you know do
you think it was click maybe think it
was maybe first like there's some grand
marketing plan to get people talking so
they tune in to games called received
myself really good enough man well quit
how quick was it was it correct like oh
very quickly 20 minutes yeah yes an
agenda against Larry her against this
man they feel like like he's a dinosaur
they want to move from house so any type
of thing that they can attach to that's
in a negative fashion they're trying to
push them you know get him out of here
type of thing
let's get Microsoft younger or whatever
Larry herb is our uncle Larry herb does
his job to perfection and I like Larry
herb stuff now I don't know what these
people have against them
he's a nice face of the franchise oh you
have other faces the franchise for
PlayStation remember that fake Larry
herb that they had over there for the
commercials he's done right they throw
them in the bushes Larry is here to stay
and until Larry wants to step away leave
Larry alone
Paul said Larry Dee's we put out the
passenger
real thing that's a real thing
hashtag you're going in right there the
chat is telling you exactly what the
consensus is and I've seen it and I'm
like wow I and that's the only only
thing I can say is Wow
Larry held down the fort through the
good in the bed let Larry repose rewards
when you know Xbox launches the next
system and then maybe he can go out the
past year believe Larry Larry walk all
for Larry turns I don't I don't have an
issue with Larry my thing is with with
this but in particular if the goal was
to get talking about it right it's
awesome if the goal was if people talk
about they did that for such a short
period of time like for it to them be
like you know retcon the holding rec on
that just why don't you announce it
closer to game comps it has a bigger
impact then there's a people really can
like what are they announcing oh my god
he's going in these like larry needs to
go what do you feel about the man i
don't care if he stays if he goes he
goes or sony you know I don't know I
feel like for when you when you watch
inside Xbox I feel like Larry's
retirement time is coming you watch
inside Xbox
I feel like he'll eventually step way
and you'll see Graham Boyd probably
stemming to his rago's mm-hmm and
they've got a really talented group of
younger guys like to school just looking
if you watch inside Xbox there's a lot
of talented people involved in that show
and there'd be a lot of people that
would be willing to do the step up I
hate that show and Larry's been in the
industry for a long long time and I love
the fact that he absolutely drums up the
glove meme I love that he lives
is the clean he's the pristine Larry is
the you can't have a new system launched
without the gloves going around I
wouldn't deny that that assessment right
there
you know mr. Rogers is the old childhood
guy that has not been little Bliss's
ashtag save Larry
all right we see a Silurian I don't like
that inside Expo stuff I don't like it
it's can't the flairies not good for
that mm-hmm let's remove Larry off of
that but when Larry giving you games of
the month and when you're looking at
what's coming out for games at a month
and he's click and go and Larry's
reading off their prompter Larry is the
best in the business I think what
sometimes connect okay today when it
comes to stuff like this you know that's
debatable if it was on accent or not but
when it comes to like live camera you
know how many interviews does this man
have a year when's the last time he did
a PR nightmare no duh like never why I
can't even when's the last time he said
something that you know people latch on
to and misinterpret because he knows how
to handle questions and if it's not
right why don't we want to touch that
thank you that's all I got of anything
else on our games console we can move on
I mean we go all over the place you know
that those are my peoples and I'll heard
cyberpunk 2077 is gonna make a crater so
I'm dying to see that but that's all I
got so lord solve crack down back
and in the news what's going on yeah so
speaking about games common things we
may or may not see I gave so you're a
gamer published an article last week
talking about the development of
crackdown and basically the tough time
that it's had from its inception all the
way to its different showings and the
expectations people had for the game the
times the game changed hands in terms of
development the fact that the game
hasn't had strong leadership in terms
and unity of vision and what that means
for the game that we'll be getting in
February and the tone that I got from
the article uh leads me to believe that
they have some sort of insider knowledge
indicating that that game is still not
ready to go mmm
and that's what scares me a little bit
about the game listen it's a game it's
not you know the end-all be-all but for
a game to have this much issue all the
way to its development not get cancelled
right and to come out and be less than
good mmm it's gonna be a big
disappointment um for people who love I
love crackdown think characters great
I'm after playing the original crackdown
I'm back compatibility ice I went out
and definitely said I don't want to see
that game again I don't want that either
um and there's something specific in the
article that Phil Spencer said he said
listen this last this last delay came
from me playing the game right I came
for two things me realizing that the
release window that we had for it now
insane it's absolutely insane to release
it in the fall this year
exactly it isn't called it the blast
beyond that that's a valid reason beyond
that he said I played the game and I
loved crackdown and it didn't feel right
Mario
on the original or was it the second
crackdown but wasn't he
overseeing Microsoft games at that part
that's what bothers me about that last
statement is that a year out from launch
less than a year out from launch you're
saying the game doesn't feel right so
what I got to ask you guys is what what
game do you think we're getting in
February the thing is with crackdown 3
is like i-i've been I covered crackdown
3 exclusively on the website all the
bumps and all the things that issues
that have gone on with it and there was
three companies working on crackdown 3
originally there's sumo digital the one
that escapes me right now and then there
was the cloud engine which was handling
all the multiplayer destruction well the
other one developer dropped out last
year cloud engine just the head guy was
head guy is there yeah Dave Jones he
quit and he is now part of Epic Games
and he's part of the fortnight movement
now and his company went with him so
cloud engines now part of for now not
part for tonight it's now part of Epic
Games so that Epic Games is using that
company to their full potential now so
the only people that are still working
on crackdown 3 sumo digital which they
do a fantastic job they have some great
games in their cat their catalogue but I
don't know if they've got the scope to
deliver on the promises they've been
saying with this and not on debt I heard
that on a shout to Jes Gordon what's my
dude Xbox - yay - Jays um I heard that
um the single-player is still being
worked on
generally right now as far as as far as
it sits everything is still being worked
on as for like from what I know and Jess
would have better sources than I would
in that regard but as far as like people
are saying that this game is still far
if they need another delay but they shut
out the Xbox Xbox for eight we were
talking about this yesterday and I got a
lot of credit to his insight on certain
things but I went back to the original
source of the game when they showed the
game and they showed the game in his
form when it was doing the
destructibility remember when they shot
down that building in the building fell
in the slow motion yeah all right now
look at the graphics in that game right
and I don't know what system they were
using but it made me feel like trip
Hawkins was back the capital of the
finesse team listen I've never been
finesse in the fashion of chip Walker
trip Hawkins was a master showman he was
a magician live in the flesh he showed
you things that really wasn't there
he lied in the inner face with a smile
and padded across but that man is the
ultimate if you want to get something
sold he's bringing trip trip is gonna
get it sold no matter what cuz what you
see is not what you get but what you get
is not what you see and I think they did
that and they thought they can reach
that goal I saw that original video
again yesterday and after seeing what we
got now the systems in the games that we
play nothing looks like that game that
we got now it would look like that a
quick little piece from the article it
says Jones eye-catching demo that showed
the impressive destruction tech in a
multiplayer crackdown themed environment
it turns out was only ever about showing
off the potential mobster out it was
never intended to represent gameplay
gamers might actually get to experience
yeah that's what happened we're married
to that Hill Zone two people don't
understand what Jones is like his whole
purpose wasn't to make crackdown 3 the
most amazing thing ever you just try to
sell his cloud engine software he was a
crackdown 3 to sell his cloud engine
software and how well it runs and
everything else and crackdown 3 demoing
well would have done really really well
for him right and everyone was like
everyone went full in on that company
after that first absolutely now my
question you undid is do you think that
is a finesse do you feel miss little
misled after now that no the layers are
coming off dude it is your game look
I'll be honest with you I never had an
interest in crackdown flight from one
two and three like there's there's no
interest there however on the
technological standpoint that what they
were trying to achieve with three it
picked my interest because thank you
mean you the same yep yeah because like
what this could bring to other games if
this was would be amazing dude let me
jump in you got me excited dude like I'm
in the same position as you know under I
am NOT a crack down guy from the very
beginning even I think I only bought the
first one wasn't gonna packing with the
halo 3 yeah yeah I did not care about
that game we did nothing for me no
disrespect to the people love it is just
not my cup of tea right I'm like I'm
getting that halo early so I guess I
gotta play this game you know with the
whole thing is completely when the cloud
destruction part was announced in debut
from a technical standpoint cuz I'm a
techie that excited me I'm like okay so
finally we can see some real-world
implementation of quote-unquote a
politic look the first thing my brother
thought when he saw that I know King
David's gonna get a kick out of this is
like we are one step closer to having an
open-world halt
oh that would be total destruction of a
city runnin loose with the whole and
just get a were like yo the assets are
all being done in the cloud and you know
we many times the competition microsoft
up for a huge for what that's going to
lead into my topping and i'm gonna do
that later and what i understand what
that did for microsoft at the time and
for for the sale of that software yes of
course he trip Hawkins the hell out of
he did alright he did and maybe it
doesn't come out this generation that
that software works in the capacity or
the form that he wants it to unless you
have optimal us a cpu power to do that
of course the board do the cloud and let
those computations come down right okay
maybe it doesn't happen then but maybe
it happens in the future but that man
sold his software and he did it in a
very spectacular fashion that he cries
[Music]
[Applause]
job title and epic has nothing to do
with cloud engineering goal is the is
there eSports no to be fair to him no it
wasn't nest it wasn't him finessing that
and just moving on this is part of the
problem that the game has had to its to
its entire development that it's changed
hands a number of times that is correct
so it isn't necessarily his fault
because he said people came on and
became the primary developer like his
his involvement in the game was only
advisory so his involvement just
continue to diminish not necessarily
because he chose it that way yeah so you
know it is one of those things this is
another thing that's interesting to me
mmm-hmm they recently talked about you
know getting the game to the finish line
and what that means right
so they put Ken lob in charge of making
sure that the team
maintains focus like how did you not
have this type of person in charge from
the very beginning making sure there's
focus yeah and you're hitting goals that
are hittable right and it just seems
like everything from like in inception
of the concept how they wanted to expand
on the concept to its execution there
was just nobody was on the same page
sorry can we agree that crackdown is
really the b-team oh we were concerned
with sumo digital handling a title like
this I'm talking about when I say is the
b-team we all know Microsoft has Big Mac
fries and shake right so that is the 18
right we came agree to that part right
that halo is 18 crackdown is part of the
b-team my fable Oh crackdown and
whatever the hell else I don't know my
boy
my concern is them not wanting to make
it more than what it is already but I
see I disagree with that part only
because the only thing that gives me a
little hope is when Phil himself plays
it in this light this is not a go out of
control yet when the expectations of the
B teams the beat when I say B team I'm
not talking about the development team
I'm talking about the Alec view it this
got a budget of this and let it be that
I think it got out of control
so the scalebound guy right right they
said damn wanted to catch this game we
can't we can't not let me just get this
one point of cake is you making
fantastically the ding to is just like
again when I see the comments from Phil
and like I said he said you know he's
like this is not a goal let's put some
more time in and now this you're a game
when it comes and let's be honest like
Phil really has been transparent with
this whole situation like really went
bad information to try to get sources
like Eurogamer is getting the sources so
clearly hears about this game enough to
try to get this out there the only
concern I have is which the elephant in
the room is kind of the titanfall 2
syndrome look at that release date also
you don't saying you just
putting it in a bad situation where it's
not attached they need to do what they
did with nothing we're putting like a
halo or some type of demo attached to
this game and nowadays you really can't
do that strategy because most of the
games is being purchased digitally and
most of the games all the games now is
going to game pass so that strategy is a
dinosaur now as a relic it can't be used
so the way that they was shoehorn in
this Trojan horse at the game to you
before that can't be done anymore no how
can we package this game to get it to us
and I think game pass is the perfect way
to Trojan horse that game to you because
basically it's hella hot water and they
figured hey game pass maybe we'll get
gonna get and this is the thing though
so do you guys think if Phil touches
that game again in January and he says
no it's not ready do you think he moves
it this is what I say yeah and I gotta
jump on this because this is gonna lead
into somewhat a poll question but the
thing is I say yo if it's still what it
is we'll just save that to scarlet let's
move this to Scott like it's clearly not
ready it's clearly still having issues
if the computational power is not there
or just change direction we've seen this
with titles like rise remember rise was
like a connect game if I remember we're
first announced there's nothing like I
understand from an egotistical
standpoint and from a perception
standpoint right it doesn't look the
greatest you delay all jala it again but
what's to me what's the alternative you
put this thing out
it's a 67 Metacritic you're gonna meet
you're gonna get killed again and
another - first party that didn't do it
you know so that my thing is just it's
okay bye I mean let's financially it's
really gonna kill them you know I'm
saying I see Xbox caught it they had a
in the back I think you probably have to
rebuild the entire game for yeah I'm
sorry they just need to cancel it well
let me get undead on this what is that
last bongani his perspective on that
well see what crackdown 3 like I still
I'm still one of those people that
they sure given they should have kept
time on scalebound in the show carry
cancers crackdown
nothing honestly like you can't take
three different studios and put them all
together and then just hope that a good
games gonna emerge from it and that's
what they tried to do with this they
didn't try coordinate they didn't have
someone those running the show of all
these three studios they had three
different studio heads with Jones doing
like a kind of overseeing kind of this
is kind of what's going on they kind of
had a couple guys in observation roles
but you didn't have someone that was
like telling Claude engine this is why I
need you guys doing they didn't have
somebody saying they're going this is
what I need sumo digital you you know it
said the doors are thin post minutes her
sides even dude yeah he can create these
yeah he didn't create these problem I
get that I guess I guess um question for
and dad in my office today like I hear
what you going it's just like like don't
you think it does more damage if it just
releases it is I'm just as a gamer I'm
just scared like this thing bombs we're
never gonna get another crack down game
right now I don't think we're gonna get
one either
we're getting to the boy you know I
don't think Kelvin was salvageable like
I think that was more of like an
internal internal class to do yeah but
you know I think crackdown I think that
communication was lost with what they
were promising and they know that if
they didn't get something even remotely
I I think they're just trying to figure
out how to sell this game to people now
is the perfect way so I got a bit that
dog I got it Mitchell goes you're told
in there
try to create some engagement and I will
say this I am looking forward to the
four player co-op game to be a hundred
with you man like I'm getting kinda
tired to talk talk read this article
sauce off one of my changes just to
juicy we had to talk oh no I get that
but like it's just like like it's like
vitta our fault it's like it no one's
fault for picking the toffee it's like
Microsoft put this game in such a bad
position toward asked we talked about
every couple months but the thing keeps
getting delayed by bigger question is
why did Microsoft decide to crack down a
franchise that was not one of their big
heavy hitters had to be a heavy hitter
this Gen Y crackdown 3 had to be if
crackdown came out and it did the moat
with the multiplayer supposed to do I
don't think this game would have an
issue but you know I think that's the
issue they can't get the multiplayer on
that point I think they if they're
you're gonna Wade your new tech on
anything that's unproven you're gonna
wade you're on like like King said a
beating like a meeting if you if they
had if they have put out a Halo video
utilizing this stuff and it didn't come
to pass in a Halo game mmm the pushback
would be much more than your right foot
and Plus like you know I get that but at
the end of the day Microsoft be taking
so many arrows like let's move on so
let's let you get anything else to
finish off your topic oh man I said I
just I want a decent crackdown game
where everybody eyeballs is on this and
you gotta have good moves
yeah there's a Sam so Lord addict you
got a good one man
scarlet talk let's get to it I just want
to like you know briefly go over this
because I I don't want to go too much
over but with the scarlet you know
whatever it's going to be called what do
you think is required at launch for the
system to be successful I want to jump
in but we gotta get to be successful and
well the thing is
okay gate like not the gate like hit the
ground running well we know what sells
comes realistic yeah we know it sells
consoles at the gate mmm-hmm price point
because let's face it it would be a
whole different start at the gate if we
had had the force connect bundle if Xbox
one didn't launch with the Kinect and
was the same price as the ps4 let's face
it Sony's launch lineup was there's not
as good as the Xbox oh it's not great
Microsoft's wasn't amazing but they at
least had a launch lineup and like if
the thing is is what you're seeing is
you see all these Studios gearing up you
see Sony's gearing up stuff you see
Microsoft's gearing up stuff I think
we're gonna see one of the best console
launches for software and hardware I
think there's gonna be games that I
think i 100% believe that the new Halo
game will be the one you steal about
because like 100 percent you want to
sell people an xbox Xbox one later goal
again mechanics can give them halo facts
and people will and especially you like
Halo new engine
reworked from the ground up you know
you're gonna hit every person that ever
owned an original Xbox of Xbox 360
you put a nice price point on that and
the services the Microsoft System
building
oh I'm Xbox one that's all going to add
up for a very very interesting start
that's it and that's the key thing is
affordability ya know it seems like a
stupid thing to to fight about now be
we're so far to the generation
everything's almost pretty much the same
price except for like the Pro and the ax
are like $100 different like the only
wiggle room we've got price-wise that's
when you launch off a console we saw
with the ps3 it was like $300 more
expensive 360 nobody wanted the ps3
Fatboy that's the thing is like price
point and software are huge pushes and
that's why if anyone if you look at the
numbers of the Xbox one and the ps4
right out the gate they were fantastic
and that's because there was no because
a lot of the games were still available
on ps3 and xbox360 for a while and the
launch games were like they weren't
fantastic so they they're looking to
give you a reason to buy it day one
because Microsoft realizes that they
can't catch up this generation they
gotta start focusing on next generation
facts you'll let me jump in and that got
me height stole my price point thing but
it's all good great minds think alike no
they have to have a lot of top um
straight out the gate strong launch like
them you gotta follow like that switch
and that Dreamcast script you gotta have
eight to ten you know I mean and Halo
infinite gotta be part of I mean doesn't
have to be obviously there's another big
game that's good fine
but if any possibility that halo
infinite is ready
I'm wait Lord and then you have to throw
that and launch you put the gauntlet
down this is our baby this is the new
engine this is what you can do so that's
one - this is a king move you got to
demonstrate power you got a showcase why
I need to even jump to this right
because at the end of the day as much as
we love the X we can't say outside
outside of the multi plans right the
multiply seat Wolfenstein oh my god 4k
60 this one oh my god but for the first
party we haven't really seen that game
it's not disrespect to see at these
because of what it looks fantastic game
HDR but you need that graphical showcase
game cuz I look I see it's more of a
like a cartoony art style you I'm saying
you need that yeah that you need that
God where you need that
when you see this like I've never seen
that before yeah
don't lose kind of moments to say okay
this is why you're gonna get that 400 or
that five whatever it is right and then
the third thing which I am pretty
confident figure is the forward
compatibility you gotta make sure yo you
good if you have yet you know
everything's coming you know I mean
that's the great thing shot out to the
great wall my man North Hills still on
the team you know obviously had me on
ILP round table you know you got a
reassure that that game is dead
library's coming with them
you still keep you know the xbox360
stopped pumping so this way gamers know
if you're with Xbox your eco system come
with you right that's what you need you
got it so it's those three things and to
me if they do that they've got a great
shot you know I'm saying and I and
obviously they got a launch either
before or at the same time as the first
that does my last chance I know if I
took up a lot of flight lissa katene for
me a big thing is the natural forward
progression of the OS I don't want to
start a new console generation with a
brand new OS telling me that after
waiting a year the best features that
I've already been using for the power
thank you for say don't do the destiny
to where you retract features that was
already successful don't do the destiny
to launch presa let's go oh you need to
move listen you need to continue to
improve the OS that you have an open you
have issues would it be in slow being
clunky whatever keep improving it just
keep improving it don't start from
scratch and tell me that I have to wait
forever to get my Dobby vision in order
to get my door whatever the heck you
would I had to whatever new OS you would
need um and then I think big for them
this year this next generation is maybe
some sort of integration with Xbox Live
and game past give me one package hmm
make it more enticing for people to jump
in the appointment I'm bigging this
looking with you me okay I think um
everybody is
be a little disappointed with what I
think Microsoft needs to do going
forward it's pretty bad what that what's
what's what's gonna actually happen all
right so it's better I've been announced
that it's three different SKUs right all
right so in these three different skills
we don't know exactly what is comprised
of these three different SKUs I think
it's a mouse and keyboard might come
with one I think is elite controller
might come with another different type
of hard drive yes man I think it's gonna
be like a bass I think it's gonna be
like a base model I don't I don't know I
don't know to be honest with you but
they have said three different SKUs
right all right so price point is
definitely key that hundred dollars you
know the the guys that wanted to make
the jump
the the loud roar against the Kinect got
to feverish and the cheap pockets went
with the cheaper place because that
that's that that's a fact when you're
walking in the store and he's saved for
this hundred dollars I can either get a
piece of hardware I really don't care
about as far as the Kinect or I can buy
games that hardware is going to lose out
if they don't care about it so it's like
forced hardware so that we don't know
how longer have to worry about that
people are complaining about the X price
being over the pro now not taking an
account that when you put on your X and
you play all these older games it hypes
those games up but you can't see that
unless you have that to understand now I
think in that ecosystem that they're
gonna have that everybody keeps telling
that okay you you be able to bring all
these games across the same complaint
that I had last week where I feel Sony
has a leg up this is the argument on
Sony side is when they cut off that
generation they come in with games that
look great
utilizing that hardware so much upon the
old pack so what you're implying that
Billy is a detriment because you know
like this support power of the system
it's a double-edged sword is the
blessing and the curse mmm
right now this is where the cloud comes
in and I think this is the part where
the cloud actually is going to help um I
think scarlet won't necessarily need the
power of the cloud right I think scarlet
was gonna be robust enough that it can
actually force those games to run native
for takers remember all these games have
scalability so when you put these games
on if they were checkerboard up I
believe in scarlet they're gonna be
running at actual 4k shout out to xbox
we talked about this yesterday we had a
great conversation um there's not
actually 4k native and 60 frames
hopefully or if it's 1080p is definitely
gonna be 60 frames I think it's gonna
push those games forward to get to that
level right and then the cloud is gonna
be used for older Xboxes because
remember they don't want to exclude
anyone if they're gonna work they're
gonna be saying stuff like well if you
have an Xbox these games are still
playable on your system with the use of
this and I believe that package comes in
they're gonna sell you on that package
that sovereign is talking about game
plan Xbox Live with the power of the
cloud you know um and that can get
across that way I don't think going
forward nothing is gonna be more
important than peaceful and I definitely
do not believe Halo is gonna be a launch
title at all mmm already okay no I don't
think so but I believe they will
definitely have something in the form of
the fable I believe they notice how
Zelda push that genre on a switch Zelda
soul switches and Zelda continues to
sell switches so if they can get a fable
but in the vein I don't think they will
be any closer
yeah but respect it's a favor do you
think it has that iconic name like where
people are gonna rush out to buy a
system that's losing my said hey no yeah
right so that's why I don't believe it
holds that cachet but I believe that
that open-world adventure game that you
can throw something graphical that
that's that that graphical showcase that
newness of it see halo is still halo but
it's still halo
you understand and it's gonna just going
to sell and I know they want to hit the
mark on that game specifically what the
newness of Fable because we were waiting
for favor when they got canceled or
something happened to it where Lionhead
studio and these people had a hunger in
for that game like addict and myself and
everybody else that once that game when
they see I believe it's going to sell
but I believe like undead said price
point more than anything it's going to
dictate victory or lost in the next
generation antique finish I could have
it I feel like I don't know like part of
me wants Microsoft to do good next-gen
but the direction they're going where
they're like pretty much like two
generations at a time I think that's
gonna be a huge problem like people are
talking about like the hair to becoming
the base model so like it oh you're not
a fan of this direction of iterative
console is because at the end of the day
if you make the X the base model you're
gonna have Sony making ps5 exclusives
that look twice as good as your game
that that do way more different things
with your game and you're still making
games for two different consoles I'm
gone my question is this know do we
really let let's talk about elephant
room with you so do we really think Sony
is not going to do full competitor 2 but
what do you think I did well I was gonna
say they see everyone seen the patents
last year or Cerny looking into doing
forward compatibility from the ps4 let's
face it we talked about this in the
gaming perspective last night we're no
longer selling consoles we're selling
pre-made pcs these aren't there's not
they're not they're not doing
independent hardware anymore I don't
know about this thing and I'm like no
more power the days of the PowerPC kind
of over I don't think Sony's changing
that I think they're gonna continue
doing generations they're gonna do
general if they don't if they sit there
and they tell people like if they
release death stranding and goes through
FEMA on ps4 and then try sell remasters
for PS 5
I think they got the eucharistic one day
and I want you to answer this one
question have they done it in the past
that has it been successful for it's
been mass successful they've made mad
money like you know people always say if
something's not broke don't fix it Sony
literally so dream master after
iteration like I get that like and I
said multiple times like if they don't
do backwards compatibility
they're full of themselves but we're at
a situation where you've seen multiple
executives saying that we look at in the
future we don't look in the past these
consoles are basically pcs I can go back
and play games from the 90s on my PC no
problem they run easily backwards and
Dewey bringing stuff from the past the
only reason that 360 and OG xbox games
are a pain because they ran on separate
Hardware on computers essentially way to
bring your Xbox one games to Scarlett
that'll be a walk in the park and these
games make it regardless with the
capabilities and the compatibilities to
go on to the PS 5 to the ps4 it's Sony
gonna want to give you the option not to
rebuy the same [ __ ] so they take that
not do it do let's be real do that they
could bring back last of us 60 frames
they can bring back uncharted 4 60
frames they can bring Last of Us to at
60 frames like not a date I hate attic
and King are making a good point in this
sense because listen I do
I'm a witch I think they don't have in
this backwards in billing but I was like
we have to look at Nintendo we got to
bring them up right and all of us in it
I me at least me I saw of a screaming
Virtual Console Masada virtue Castle
with these mini systems and so now we
still have not gotten any of these
classic games only they are being
brought on to you know NES mini Super
NES mini
maybe this revenue in that tremendous
revenue in that so it does that factor
into your decision process as well or
you still like nobody really for Sony's
gonna find with ps4 versus PS five his
there's been a switch and how people buy
video games I know there's still a lot
of people to buy physical games that's
fine
right a lot of people have gone heavy
digital this generation and we talked
about this yesterday and the big thing
is that if you have four hundred and
fifty digital games on your ps4 for
example and then PS five comes out and
you trade your ps4 in but you can't play
those games that run you'd literally
just took your console and four hundred
and fifty games you owned and they're
gone you don't physically have them
anymore you don't own them they're gone
mm-hmm I think that itself would be a
horrible move mm-hmm
I get that but at the say I see where
like David and added per se keep it then
don't sell it and you can still play
right now when it comes to gang quality
no one is touching them even a little
bit daily driver seat is markedly but -
as long as they drop their horizon zero
dawn - and that last of us - people
could say what they want they lining
about third first party exclusives we'll
get you to a point but that eventually
runs out you know look at God or yeah
you could already gone sold like five
million or one month yeah I think I
think Sony's positioned themselves
better than anyone for that not to be
the case I don't know that they ever
really gonna have a drive this is the
thing they do have absolutely
no reason to make any other stuff they
backwardly compatible first we talked
about this earlier with the og
PlayStation 3 with the hardware side we
know that they're not a software company
they are a hardware company right
alright so they're gonna go the hardware
route they're not putting the
PlayStation floor inside a PlayStation 5
so you're not gonna play these games at
all think about it because they never
tell you we never told you to get rid of
your system if you like they gotta do
that backwards compatibility but at the
end of the day like they don't go like
they really don't like you think they
keep a hard-line stance like how they
keep the hardline stance with the
fortnight is that argument that the
argument that King and adequate making
about how the layman doesn't know that
right they're gonna tell the layman like
we understand that these things are
basically PCs and they move forward
right but when you tell somebody look at
the PS 5 is brand-new you can't play
these games over here to somebody that's
the parents I'll tell you that that's a
lot of people work people they don't
can't you listen they said cross
progression which is minor or switch is
playing nice with the Xbox they looked
at you in your faces said so if you
think you're gonna make an account over
there
you can't play our stuff try to make an
account over there you your count don't
work here sir and you know what
90,000,000 says no yo shout-out to
slo-mo DJ he going hard he said you guys
need to understand when you don't adapt
you go to the way you go the way of
blockbuster
Sony needs to make some change but
here's a because if they wouldn't do
backers compiler doesn't mean they
haven't adapted look at their games
we're in the gaming industry like god
every game they've dropped this
generation just has been the defining
moments of that genre this the thing is
I will scream this from the roof
amazing first party titles
I got wars my game of the year I gave it
a 96 on my review for it but what people
need to understand is that these
single-player games while there he they
have huge success for isin zero dangan
war
these are exemptions they aren't the
rule that is true facts or sold five
million copies in a month that game
spent five years but keep saying this
like they're not gonna have a
multiplayer game this is the part that
makes absolutely zero sense right okay
we're talking about the fact that if
it's gonna be backwardly compatible I
think honestly there's a huge loss in
revenue and repackaging these games are
selling it to these guys over again
because they were against all let's be
real like situation where it made it
seem like we're friendly we're
affordable you can promote come on guys
so when you do come on guys
they are pigeon-holed right now they are
stuck so you're gonna say yo is it
possible that they can bring that power
that you can see I can tell you this
that s must've be that scarlet could be
way more powerful than that PlayStation
I can guarantee that PlayStation file
will be able to show you that power if
it's not backward-compatible and get
every drop out of that system I given
again what you're saying when it comes
to that but the way that is looking
right now it's look like I would say
horizon zero dawn two is gonna be a
launch title like I think right now cuz
the topic was about scarlet I have no
clue how we got on PS out how they did
that is the most important is when it's
coming at how much it's gonna be in what
is launching with I'm sorry if Xbox
doesn't have halo out the gate and a
good halo they they're not getting out
the gate what if what if it's another
title that maybe it's a new IP or matter
drastic I fear when you go in I'm
actually with you but what about the
alternative perspective is what if it's
like a new IP that looks you see here's
the thing like even if the call is is
good in gameplay looks phenomenal
Microsoft has done nothing to show me
that they know how to present games this
generation but I think the argument if
people the argument with Microsoft
disdain has been they they have no new
games if they launched their console
with a brand new IP they have their
horizons dude why do you keep making
this argument like you're not a layman
here the majority people buying this big
game out the gate because that's what
the talk here how many casuals you know
is gonna go out and buy a game they want
himself Dave Billy saw how many cabbage
hardcore right they want hardcore right
that's what we're talking about
out the gate now look at the cattle
market when it comes to I said out the
gate that was the whole conversation
is talking about the graphical fidelity
being held back because of the old
systems coming forward and you're
talking about what they exactly mean by
that because I just like like they're
saying that no console will be left
behind and stuff like that can't be for
generations going up for wear it just
can't happen
what addict wants and what I know it
needs to happen is it has to be a
cut-off right this is the reason why in
and you're gonna understand this part
this is the reason why when you're gonna
tell me that they're gonna lose just
y'all keep going with this PC stuff and
the sliding scale of the graphical power
as it goes on I have a hell of a PC
right here yeah all right and I know
that I can play the destiny to on a
lowest form PC there's requirements for
it so you go let's say we go bass and
now I can play it at the highest form
but this Scarlett is its highest form
right now think about the game that says
the requirement is only the highest form
and bass can't be done this right way
this is where I and I hate to cut you
where I do agree with you like we're
going iterative right this is almost
mimicking cell phones right there comes
up and I want to ask solve this question
there's some games on the Google Market
playing play on agree with that I'm not
saying that you oh gee Xbox one is at
some point at some point the bass line
has to be pushed to the side and the
next one up becomes the baseline right
but but so and he's not gonna be doing
that though they're going to be making
for that hard work sure it might not be
day one because obviously most things
are for both systems but there's going
to come to that point where games are
being solely made for ps5 and the Xbox
one X and their Xbox to whatever it's
called they're gonna be main gains for
them but this is the thing though
they're so good at es5 you're assuming
the PS 5 is some bespoke piece of
hardware with like with some
crazy ridiculous engine in it that's not
how they're making consoles anymore
they're making consoles like pcs that's
what we're trying to say we're not like
if you're talking about like ps3 and
whatever healthy emotion engine or
whatever the hell was in it yeah that's
how they used to build game game
consoles before that's not how they're
building them anymore Sony and Microsoft
Apple nobody into iron being of so wait
we think you think they're gonna go a
different architecture and leave I just
think they don't care do put the work in
that like I don't think they actually
care they're not so here to make it easy
oh you noticed a joint their joint is
wait come on come on get over here you
know what it is no game pass makes it so
that hey we all are here we're family
together yellow Saudi don't pay for it
Sony doesn't kick yo they're gonna I'm
telling you when you play that
PlayStation you will not be putting our
PlayStation 4 this in there you will not
be taking your transfers over you will
not be doing that stuff they have shown
you constantly step up get out of lay
down and people have been getting up 90
million have got up so they don't care
about oh you wanna hear with your own
system just that's your fault go back
and get it
don't do that keep both they were
anything or think I'm probably showed
it'll probably show you a video we'll
both of them together this is how you
play old PlayStation
that's cool but when that God award two
jobs like crazy I feel what you say they
see something to get down or lay down
you know they're gonna force your wallet
you know it because it happens all the
time when they show you joy that can
only be played here when I say only here
I will say this and this is where Kings
are given astray addicts are going
strong when you're in the market leader
you're in the position of power history
has shown that those companies tend to
be a little arrogant and anti-consumer
because they're in a position like that
you get to the point like it depends
where their hubris meter is the largest
community they they they are so fulla T
stove they said that's a you problem
get over we gotta move what we over like
crazy but this is a great Oh God oh so
we know that PlayStation or we assume
that PlayStation has doubled the sales
of Microsoft right and everyone is
talking about this generation like
Microsoft is a loser but we have
constantly saw that year on in Microsoft
has posted gains in revenues and in
market share in both divisions in
Microsoft and and Xbox it has shown that
it has sold as far as money-wise
I probably outpacing the
PlayStation in some regards they have
services that are set up for the future
this goes back to the last conversation
with game paths and Xbox Live they make
tons of money in these areas and they're
set up for the future my question is in
knowing that they're up 39 percent in
revenue from last year and up 34 percent
and Xbox Live and Game pass revenue did
they really lose this generation when
they're making money hand over fist its
16 billion as a company this year and
Microsoft contributed I believe it was 6
billion to that 16 billion
mm-hmm then they really lose mmm this is
my lord I'm did what do you think that
the finances are coming out and the
revenue with software services revenue
was up 36 percent gaming revenue was up
39 percent the Xbox division as a whole
finance he seems to be doing all right
what do you think you know this means
towards gaming for the future and just
maybe the rhetoric going out there well
what Phil Spencer and the Xbox division
has done very very well is they
recovered from a very very bad hand
they're dealt by Don Mattrick
right off the lot and what they've
decided to do is they can't outsell Sony
ins consoles Sony's got these games they
got all this stuff that's going for them
that they can't compete with they can't
fix the games problem off the hop Sony
was working on this problem back on the
ps3 and they kicked off ps4 and they've
been working on this ever since it's
gonna take Microsoft some time to get
the software to where it needs to be so
what they've decided to do is today
bring in the revenue that they're not
getting from the software ends of things
they're using services and try to be
more consumer friendly to get more it's
not necessarily making people go and buy
Xboxes Xbox is consistently third place
and MPD's people aren't going out and
buying Xbox is because their consumer
friendly people are spending more money
on their Xboxes because it's consumer
friendly and because the services are
available their game past is fantastic
if you're a casual gamer you have access
to over a hundred games of all different
genres whether it's 360 games OG games
Xbox one games
first party games first there people are
people are buying into that people are
you know buying live to play multiplayer
games with their friends what Phil
Spencer and company have done is they've
made it easier for people or easier for
people to want to spend money on their
console so they're good they're not
moving as many units but they're selling
making more money off of the software
people are investing in in those units
got you sucka pointment valid point
Lord Lord I'm solving a lot addict hell
like anyway if you talk about it in the
conversation of gaming mm-hmm with the
opponents that they have is oh lost I'll
go in the building family to the row man
when out early don't even worry about it
continues off with you know style you
know in the building it's just an L
that's all it is now dad said like and
like any champion if you take an L and
you don't learn from your mistakes
mmm that's on you that's your fault and
what Microsoft has done is they haven't
put their tail between their legs every
single mistake they made and it put
themselves in a position to be
considerably better moving forward no I
am more excited now for Xboxes future
than I was at the start of this
generation before the Xbox one got
announced and whatever they put
themselves in that position they just
have to execute they have to execute and
and by that I mean they need to have
games they need to have games that
people want to be on their platform to
play um and when I say their platform I
mean you know PC Xbox one exclusive
whatever that means um they have to be
games that you cannot play on a
Playstation and I know is it the
initiatives game fails if game over game
over but this brand they're putting so
much money into this
cinematic it would be they said
quadruple a you respect that name it's a
rat why
Louis lost Aldo what do you think man
now that that Microsoft finance rules
have come out and you know it's looking
pretty positive as far as revenue and it
says software and services revenue up
36% gaming revenue you know up thirty
nine percent so this constant growth you
know in exam four is that division and
obviously statements by Satya
you know saying that um you know Xbox is
plans to be a pillar as far as you know
their business and Azure and all that
kind of stuff you know what do you feel
just moving on forward do you feel like
about the doom and gloom that most
gamers have about Microsoft you know
does this quell that this is a spell
that or you need more and see more I
need to see more yeah I like to see a
little bit more what they're planning on
doing once you know kind of like what
you guys are talking about before I want
to see what this start doing games gone
I don't want to see a little bit more on
what they're what they're gonna what
their progression is gonna be I mean
that's what it is to me anyway all about
them games right it's all about what
you're gonna see what I am saying last
time we eat some exclusives we need no
doubt I'm with you man I'm with you on
that Lord King this your topic you know
actually I'll jump in for you yeah I
mean listen I'm with Stahl though in the
sense that like yo you know this first
one it is great I'm what solving this
and think this is great new right it
dispels the myth that you know the Xbox
division is so much trouble doom and
gloom and you know a lot of the fanboys
kind of run behind that rhetoric so
that's good to see
and it's good to see the commitment we
sees you know feel at the top of the
table now right that's really positive
you know gaming related moves to e3
Infinity Gauntlet moment you know where
they had Studios announced and I loved
all that stuff it gave me like soft said
tremendous positivity for the future of
the brand and yeah ten 10 billion in
revenue ain't nothing to sneeze at
you know me so like but like sloths now
those like it's got to transform into
games at the end of the day you know
it's great to dead doing well it's great
that game fast
get out the [ __ ] you know you don't know
that but we got to see it you know and
once we see that that kindly put you
know finally Chris that stamped down
like yo they here these are the
investments that we remember I want to
be talking about this ILP you know three
years down the road when said at
announcement by the initiative or you
know this or what compulsions new game
or you and I mean like I want to see
those games come to fruition and let
them be quality games so then we can say
y'all they on it you know I mean this
was this was a good investment so that's
pretty much what I got but King to
finish up its own topic do what they got
to do today um I can only say this I say
in positive revenue no one gets fired
right so okay good so when everything is
positive we keep the same status quo and
maybe we add pieces to it now we've been
seeing them adding pieces to it you
can't go fast if you don't have an
engine you can't go fast if you don't
have gas you can't go fast if you don't
have wheels Microsoft got a car ready to
go fast and start from the gate um Sony
is already down the track so there's no
need to try to catch up to him in this
race they're gonna wait for the next
race they're getting a that's an order
they're getting everything ready I
really honestly believe undead headed
out the park when he said price point is
definitely key
I think price point dictates everything
and I understand Microsoft believes that
I know they know that they can't say we
just have games and you're gonna come
over here or we just have services and
you're gonna come over here and have a
dumb price point I believe the price
point will be very smart
I believe the games will be an effect I
believe that they have the studio's
ready to move and you will be
comfortable with the people that are in
charge because these people have shown
you positive growth all the way through
when a company that doesn't have to look
down parent company doesn't have to look
down on the smaller company and make
changes that means that that company can
go forward and do exactly what y'all
looking for they're listening to you
they're watching us right now
and then understanding your concerns and
I honestly believe out of every company
this generation they have shown it
listened to you and they have
implemented a lot of stuff going for it
so that the next system that you can be
comfortable with purchase and they're
trying to keep their core we're now
going outside the box they're trying to
keep their core base they want the same
45 to 50 million to purchase 45 to 50
million whatever scarlet is gonna be a
better position moving forward in any of
the big three they are best positioned
and and to me second place would be
Nintendo can in tendo's considerably
forward-thinking considering what we
think about Nintendo
I think Sony I will talk about and in
the last topic Sony at this point isn't
playing so much to win he's playing kind
of to lose not to lose you think so it
just feels safe it you're in dominant
position and you're safe you're not
pushing you're not pushing both barriers
anymore
alright I hear what you're saying but
only reason why I slightly disagree is
because of the fact but let's be real my
stuff don't really need Xbox like that's
a component of what made me like Sony's
whole company you know for the rest of
their parts of their business is not
doing well the PlayStation is the
driving force now that division so they
kind of gotta be hungry and hustling out
here in these streets because otherwise
places it doesn't do well they go under
what no but I don't I don't mean about
that I mean obviously we talked about
the first party stuff they have that
unlock and they're gonna continue to
have that unlock right but my thing is
will quit Microsoft is pushed forward in
terms of services in terms of in terms
of the online stuff stuff that they've
been sort of reluctant to take I feel
yes you can take me to lead on
innovations that are the future okay I
got you exactly so they had the lead and
they're like okay this is how we got
here we'll hold it onto this we're not
gonna push the envelope right now
we're okay I got to shout out to Mike
Emily Chad don't forget y'all Ataris
coming back and throat Ari and close the
bushes and zip it back up everyone can
thank anything microsoft does going for
word to the fact of how well Sony did
its generation because you know what
happened you know what changed for this
Sony started making insane amounts of
money with the ps4 and ahead of my
Microsoft sat there went this gaming
stuff is actually profitable like look
let's face it like Terry Myerson
throttle Xbox is it thought it was the
most useless division Microsoft division
he was quoted as saying he thought the
mobile division was more important than
their games division we all know you
guys have had Jeff Gordon on here you
know how Windows Phone like that that's
the thing is like they it is profitable
they want a bigger part of the pie that
and that's the thing that they were
going for the head of Microsoft is
straight out comments that the gaming is
more of a focus for them going forth
they bought beam turned it to mixer and
mixers actually gaining some traction
yeah they're they're doing things right
and that's the thing is I think it's
gonna take a couple of years but I
actually think the Xbox one is in a
better position going forward than they
were with the Xbox 360 heading into the
next generation because that's remix
Road multi plats and Call of Duty have
anything prepared for the expo damn you
killing it you killing it at my last
point I know I gotta go but you're
killing it and it's just like you made a
good point about that direction and like
I said I'm a peanut more guy but I have
to say the long term thinking that Phil
is doing and the job of turning this
whole thing around and when we talk we
talk about the upper echelon of the Xbox
hierarchy this is what I feel now put
Phil in position to ascend and we know
put his name in lights
he's just do me the finishing job is
just the game I know y'all I will give
it up I will give it up to King then rod
and you you've been preaching the vision
and I'm starting to see it I'm starting
to see it and I definitely they just got
he just got a close to deal with that
and then yeah to the point I'm gonna get
it definitely you know set up for the
future we'll see we'll see what happens
and I'm saying I mean with the Sony
thing it's gonna be interested it's
gonna be very interested generations but
that's all I got we ran crazy over we
got into shows
who do I owe with the recent article by
Eurogamer on the progress and state of
crackdown 3 development what do you
think xbox should do in terms of its
release four choices yar a keep the
release date Phil was right to delay
crackdown 3 be scrapped crackdown 3
entirely it's a mess
C move crackdown 3 to Scarlett or D I
don't care it's gonna be a free rental
in-game pass anyway that when it goes up
tomorrow Lord on day an absolute
pleasure to have you in the brown do
wick in the 5 people find you what you
got going on alright people can find me
on Twitter at undead 3 XVI I read a
bunch of articles I do a bunch of hot
takes through the week
not really I basically throw stuff up on
Twitter while I'm on break and then to
come back and see how much of a dumpster
fire it is and yeah you can find me on
youtube at undead 3 xvi and we're gonna
be starting to do a little bit of
streaming on mixer which you can also
find it on dead 3x we are no dead what
about that game with perspective man
where can five people plug your show bro
fun gaming perspective at 8 p.m. Eastern
Time on a Saturday where I have
drunkenly lead our show at new a
fantastic list of topics and we talked
about varying things in games and we got
some big stuff coming up in August I
can't talk we got some big industry
guests coming up sighs nice like what
you guys are doing man fantastic panel I
love this team you're assembled you're
gonna mean it's really good I like what
you're doing very positive and like I
set up court last night with Lord
stinger and that was a really good
episode please pay attention to what
these guys doing man
positive garden community tells us how
it is very balanced opinions a pleasure
to have you in the ground Lord I'm dead
thank you for having me you already know
and of course let's now don't wait the
last-minute additions dream team in the
building any announcement surface team
let us know
this is this is the plan so I would like
to first of all thank the ILP crew of
you know David and an addict and sob and
congees offer you know help me put this
all together and so we got a little bit
of stream schedule certain for my
information we are starting this week
today but technically tomorrow we're
still looking for a couple more people
to fill out the rest of the days so if
we want to get with you know DM Lord
addict on Twitter Andy's going through
people to go through but as of right now
we have people we have miss l-boogie
on yes yes thank you he's gonna be doing
a date/time cast for us I'm it's 1:00 to
3:00 Eastern Standard Time or 10:00 to
12:00 from Pacific Pacific Standard Time
and then Thursday we have super-g he's
going to be from p.m. to 10:00 user
standard or 5:00 to 7:00 and then myself
on Friday from 7 p.m. to 10 p.m.
maybe a little longer I don't know it
all depends what's going on that's four
to seven seven standard time and then
addict I think because he hasn't told me
exactly what hard to get home I like to
rename him the Riddler because he always
with a question to make my intro longer
man so I think he's gonna said he's
gonna be doing it on Sundays I assume
right after the stream schedule but when
I'm around four-ish five ish yeah so
more than likely it'll be right after
this the way you guys were running so I
would like to tell everyone here though
we would greatly appreciate it for you
guys to come in even if it is just to
say yo what's up and then just leave the
window open say hey you know what's goin
on you know just drop it in say what's
up see how you doing and
you know we would love to see the
community grow and let's hang out with
everybody else and keep your eye on the
Twitter the ILP Twitter so that we can
end up you know you can see what's going
on what's changing if you know something
happens you know where we're gonna be
adding another person and adding other
days like sliding a time an hour or
something like that so we would really
appreciate if you guys do that and I'll
let say thanks again for if you guys for
this opportunity to you know help this
ILP to team and the podcast grow the the
name for us is iron Lord pot iron Lords
podcasts on switch on twitch.tv slash
iron Lords podcast that's why I
appreciate you man like again and shout
out to like I said Lord addict King
coming up with the ideas and stuff like
that and this lesson although just
really putting it together I mean very
excited about this you know getting a
game community and getting a schedule
together and we try to do this man so I
get like like soullow said if you guys
can jump in there for a minute just hit
that like you know really trying to get
this thing popping and engagement with
the gamers you know cuz at the end of
the day it's all about the game so shout
out more loud Oh Lord addict where can I
find people find you what you got going
on you can find me on Twitter you can
find me on YouTube gaming addict um and
make sure actually uh
IOP definitely been streaming on there I
will be streaming on Twitch as well only
for the IOP I won't be streaming on my
actual channel but you know appreciate
them from coming by see you next week no
doubt Lord solve whether people find you
what's going on fire bloat up streaming
horizons
Oh streaming online
[Laughter]
ladies selfish experienced games can we
at least get a stream oh I'll talk it to
the wrong dude just stop
DS v6 is saw what's up with them codes
next week baby you got a giveaway
Facebook and Twitter and listen we have
combat talk this week we're gonna talk
about Mikey we're gonna talk about
Robert Easton jr. with this big fight
that's coming up next Saturday so I'm
gonna fight a breakdowns
I'm gonna give you prediction and I'm
gonna give you results you're gonna have
four shows this week but I didn't give
you anything this weekend we had some
stuff that was going on this weekend but
I didn't feel like it was combat talk
worthy until they step their game up I'm
not gonna bring you anything fraudulent
but I LP on Instagram Facebook and
Instagram is late y'all please to Graham
is finally Wow get in there and see
stuff that you have more then we got
things I got pictures I got I got
pictures that is going to blow your mind
afraid of what I drop every day and they
wake up and they see some lunatic they
hate but I'm gonna tell you right now
get in there
alright Facebook it's more or less you
know for the promo to let you know the
schedules and stuff like that so stream
team you can get that information there
better you get all of that from this
interaction you want to talk to me you
want to go at me I'm gonna light and I'm
gonna retweet everything that you say
you see King in that suit he looks like
a pimp that was full of dust for the big
fold I was a bit head burn day but yo he
just subscribed to the game of
perspective that's what size we want to
see finish up game so listen man that's
that's that's exactly where we're at
with it but I'm gonna tell you right now
catch us on every social media so you
can see where we at in these events and
what's going on
we want you to have engagement with ILP
24/7 if you have a question if you want
to see us playing video games you want
to talk to us we are accessible we are
not exclusive we are inclusive pure
gaming is the model 100% Noah King is
spoken you know what's a give me a
salute again note on that can't thank
you enough coming absolutely really
preaching please follow this man or
Twitter and and again multiverse show as
well as the gaming perspective again
salute to all the newest ILP patreon
subscribers it means so much to us man
you have no idea how humbling that is to
see you guys rock with us going on
journey super shout out to those guys of
the iron bank you know I'm saying
obviously the YouTube media car box will
get the media up later today of course
flashpoint 23 witty pontus is up we kind
of go in on Game Informer spoiling a
little bit too much but although a good
show please catch that and if anybody
got anything else we could wrap this
thing up anybody there
alright everybody enjoy everybody enjoy
your Sunday